[Music]
right here I saw your beautiful post
bringing Goldy to meet your dad
he just was loved her forever and in the
assisted living place he lives he has
her picture overfed like he loves he's
loved our whole family loves Goldie but
but he's just been looking forward to
meeting her so long it was it was really
beautiful to get to see them me now II
think I finally made it that you know
Goldie Hawn yeah you at the mat gala was
everything it looks like you had an
incredible night you and Kate I love
that what was the hilar the highlight uh
you know what I would say was going out
there and feeling really strong and good
about myself and also I I had the nicest
conversation with Kim Kardashian we
talked about everything we'd never
really gotten a spot before she was so
amazing and down-to-earth and insightful
and I really enjoyed my time with her
yeah we never really got to talk before
it's gonna hack good to be good
exchanged numbers to be further yeah
yeah
[Music]
you